United States Navy SEALs are some of the
nation's most elite warriors they're
also among the most secretive but for
the first time some seals are breaking
their code of secrecy to speak publicly
about drug abuse in the ranks some
inside the community say the growing
problem puts the entire force at risk
David Martin has been investigating and
is at the Pentagon David good morning
good morning Navy SEALs have become the
rock stars of the American military and
famous for everything from their
notoriously tough training to high-risk
missions like the bin Laden raid but
inside the SEAL Teams they are fighting
a different kind of enemy that's captain
Jamie sands commander of SEAL Teams
based on the East Coast talking to his
men last December people that we know of
that we hear about have tested positive
for cocaine methamphetamine heroin
marijuana ecstasy that's a problem three
Navy SEALs one active duty two retired
agreed to talk to us on camera if we
disguised their faces and substituted
their voices to protect them from
retribution how prevalent is drug abuse
in the SEAL Teams it's growing the drug
use it's growing during the three months
he had been in charge sans kicked five
men off the SEAL Teams for using drugs
to deal with the problem he halted
training and ordered a safety stand-down
all 900 SEALs under his command were
required to attend this meeting or watch
it online before sands spoke his chief
of staff had rattled off what he called
a staggering number of drug cases which
he said showed that the Navy's special
operators had a higher incidence of drug
use than the rest of the fleet why would
seals whose lives depend on their
physical skills take drugs
think it's okay because they've seen
other people do it they think their
teammates won't turn them in they think
it's kind of a cool thing to do but they
think it's okay according to these three
seals who take drugs don't have to worry
about their teammates turning them in
you stand up for what's right and you
get blackballed or driven out it's a
career killer and drugs aren't the only
problem according to interviews emails
and text messages from eight current and
former seals there's been a corruption
within the teams one of them wrote
another said the death of our quiet
professionalism continues to erode at
our ethos and in dangers our team mates
overseas not to mention our families at
home the community has got to stop
seeking the limelight and exposing what
they do or it continues to put people in
danger they accused fellow seals of
profiteering or as they called it
selling the Triton a reference to the
insignia they earn after making it
through basic training you don't come
out of this
I think the same fitness routines based
on SEAL training has become a cottage
industry as have books by former seals
they're just guys that are going in to
try and sell the brand to sell that
trident on their chest to make a buck
from it and frankly if that's all they
were doing so what but the thing they're
selling is information these men say
movies like zero dark thirty and Captain
Phillips are all too accurate in showing
the way seals operate one movie Act of
Valor included active-duty SEALs in the
cast they get all of these sometimes ex
seals are active duty seals to help make
sure it looks as realistic as possible
in the process you know unknowingly
or knowingly they're giving away our
tactics and procedures as long ago as
2012 seven Navy SEALs were disciplined
for having worked as paid consultants on
the video game Medal of Honor Warfighter
video games do they really give away
real tactics how we move and you know
they were pretty accurate for a lot of
different things you know so yeah I
would say some of them they do do you
ever have to change the way you operate
because something's been been made
public
yeah it all adds up to a betrayal of the
seals own code of conduct when I joined
the Navy the brochure said quiet
professionals and that's what I signed
up for but that's not what it is today
so his fame ruining the seals I believe
that has a lot to do with it
in response to our story the Naval
Special Warfare command said we had
ignored data which shows their rate of
testing positive for drugs is lower than
the rest of the Navy
but at that meeting we showed you the
seal chief of staff used significantly
higher numbers saying there had been a
hundred and thirty-five drug cases in
the past two years he also said that was
higher than the rest of the Navy's there
is a video of that speech but the Navy
refused to release it to us
Alex David thanks that's a fascinating
and distressing picture of what's
happening in the the interesting thing
is that many of these seals do not go
through annual drug testing because
they're deployed and now the commander
has said there is going to be drug
testing while they're home and while
they're deployed so the message is clear
cut it out zero tolerance what surprises
me I mean drugs influence and affect so
many different sectors of our society
but that's the one place you thought it
would not have impact that's true indeed